Fox and Friends invited Dr. Foushee on TV
and Brian kill me to try to explain medicine
to Dr. Foushee, and it really didn't go well.
Now we have a number of different Fox News
sort of related clips today.
We already did Fox News trying to rewrite
history, pretending they were always taking
the virus seriously.
And what has happened on Fox News over the
last eight weeks regarding coverage of the
virus has been borderline criminal.
I'm not saying it is criminal, but Fox News
is being sued and they likely will be sued
more times for their spreading of disinformation
about the virus.
Later, we'll get to more about that.
But for now, here's what happened.
I have a clip for you from Fox and Friends
where they invited on Dr. Anthony Foushee.
Dr. Anthony Foushee, of course, the top infectious
disease doctor in the country.
And Brian, Kill Me tried to explain to him
how medicine works and it didn't go well.
So let's get right into the clip.
What they're talking about when we pick it
up is a survey.
It's not a clinical study.
A survey of doctors around the world.
And in the survey, doctors were asked, what
are you giving people for Corona virus treatment?
And it's really important to understand that
it is a survey.
And they also ask, what have you seen?
Be effective when you've given it to people.
We are linking to the survey.
I will talk about the survey momentarily.
But let's take a look at the clip.
Listen to Brian kill.
Meade's confident, ignorant arrogance, trying
to explain medications to Dr. Foushee and
then pay special attention to the silence
at the end of the clip, which shows that Foushee
realizes there is not actually a factual assertion
to address.
While Brian kill.
Mead is just sitting there waiting, expecting
75 percent of all everyone in Spain is taking
with success French and Chinese take it and
the doctors are taking it.
There's a lot of positive things in it.
I will be very curious, Doctor, to see if
anyone has taken this for lupus or arthritis
has gotten the corona virus.
That'll be one way to go, the other way to
see about this study.
But let's talk about some way to get get good.
Do want to respond to that?
No.
I mean, obviously, this is a good drug in
many respects for some of the diseases you
mentioned.
And the one thing we don't want to happen
is that individuals who really need a drug
with a proven indication don't have it available.
But just one guy I can't escape getting back
to said 75 percent of doctors think that it
work.
We really don't care what 75 percent think
it works.
You know, that's not the issue.
No, no.
I should clarify, because I said Spain, 72
percent of the doctors in Spain are prescribing
it.
OK, good.
OK, well, that's fine.
We almost need a new term called Fox splaining.
Foushee has to be commended for being endlessly
patient with completely clueless people.
So this study, as claimed by Brian KILMEADE,
is the source of a ton of disinformation.
It's a survey which asked doctors indicate
which medications, if any, you have personally
prescribed or have seen used in your setting
to fight Kovac, 19 and indeed sixth.
1 percent of doctors in Spain have prescribed
or seen chloroquine prescribed.
Then the survey asks and again, it's just
an it's an observational survey based on the
memory of doctors of the medications you've
personally prescribed or seen used.
Please indicate which ones are most effective.
And again, globaly, you have 37 percent saying
we think chloroquine is the most effective.
But also remember that chloroquine is one
of the most used.
The numbers are not adjusted for that.
Thirty two percent say Zithromax antibiotics.
Thirty two percent say nothing has been effective.
And then you've got other stuff.
So think through the data.
37 percent on a survey say chloroquine seems
to be the most effective.
Thirty two percent say antibiotics.
It just so happens chloroquine is also one
of the most used and antibiotics have been
some of the most used.
That does not suggest to me that we have proper
data or anything approximating a randomized
clinical trial.
Thirty two percent altogether say nothing
has been the most effective.
So even if this wasn't a survey like, imagine
that instead of just being a survey of what
do doctors remember?
Imagine that this was some kind of properly
controlled test.
These numbers still don't actually tell us
that much about chloroquine.
So we've got to be really, really careful
about this stuff.
Now, I hope chloroquine works.
I hope anything works.
I have no ideological attachment to chloroquine
with or without a zero Meissen.
Trump has been touting it.
So Fox is touting it.
You need real doctors to test this stuff.
This is how you end up in these fact free
worlds where the opinion of Brian kill.
Mead in the minds of many Fox viewers is worth
just as much as the opinion of Dr. Anthony
Foushee, who, by the way, now needs armed
security because of the threats from Trump
ists who believe that Anthony Foushee is either
some kind of anti-Trump plant or even worse,
some kind of deep state operative.
That's the United States 2020 that we are
now living in.
So we all want something to work, but we need
to detach ourselves from the political nonsense
when we explore what might work.
That's called science.
We have dozens of existing medications that
are being tested.
There are new medications in process combinations
of those drugs.
A huge portion of trumpets are now emotionally
attached to chloroquine.
If it works great and I hope it does.
Remember, if it works.
We've been talking about it for weeks now.
Before long before Donald Trump was.
If it does work, remember, it will have nothing
to do with Trump if it doesn't work.
It will have nothing to do with Trump.
We need doctors and scientists telling us
what works.
Not Brian Kill Mead and a confused and sleepy
Donald Trump during press briefings.